- Britney Spears' dad agrees
to step down as conservator
of Britney Spears' estate,
and on top of that,
he files a petition to end the
conservatorship in general.
Some have pointed out
that Britney Spears' dad has
received quite a lot of flack
as being the longtime conservator
of Britney Spears' estate.
But recently, after her pleas in court,
he has filed a 112 page petition
where he agrees to step down,
and ask the court to actually
end the conservatorship.
Well, some have pointed out
that this could be an
entirely cynical move
for him to avoid criticism.
He writes in the petition,
"If Ms. Spears wants to
terminate the conservatorship
and believes that she
can handle her own life,
Mr. Spears believes that
she should get that chance."
But cynical move or not, the
Free Britney movement appears
to be as close as they
have ever come to success,
though we'll have to see
what happens in court.